Let's start by talking about uh the two
swords of Christ.
As you know, probably, my last book, uh
The Two Swords of Christ. Uh so, the
genesis of this book, it's about the
concept of Christian just war, but it's
also about the two military orders, the
Knights of the Temple and the
Hospitallers, basically. But, I called
it The Two Swords of Christ because both
groups, both military orders, and in
fact Christians in the medieval era
always talked about the doctrine of
Christ's two swords, which goes back to
Luke. But, in that book, basically, what
I'm trying to show you is the reason I
wrote that book and I gave it that title
is because those Christians were very
much actuated by uh the two swords
doctrine, which is basically in the book
of Luke, the Gospel of Luke, which
you're familiar with, the famous story
where Christ says to his disciples, "He
among you has no sword, go and sell your
cloak and buy one." And his uh disciples
look around, and then they say, "Behold,
Lord, here are two swords." And Jesus
says, "That is enough." Now, as we know,
that means absolutely nothing today to
modern-day Christians. Surely, Jesus
wasn't talking about swords, cuz we know
uh Jesus was the progenitor of doormat
Christianity. Well, we don't know, but I
mean, that's how it's presented. That's
what everyone seems to think nowadays.
So, clearly, he wasn't talking about
swords. He was making some
obtuse spiritual points. Well, for other
Christians, centuries worth of them, no,
what he was saying is that Christians
need two swords. Two swords are enough.
One to fight physical warfare, physical
evil, one to fight spiritual evil,
spiritual subversion.
>> [snorts]
>> That's how it was understood. That's the
two swords of Christ you've heard me
talking about and titling a book after,
500 page book. Okay, the two swords of
Christ are meant to fend off something.
What? The two swords of Satan. Okay? And
before proceeding, because uh this is a
very cyclical topic, as you will see. I
told you, past and present. You know me,
I like continuities that
evince themselves throughout the
centuries and show us patterns.
>> [snorts]
>> So, I'm going to basically preface this
livestream with the following biblical
verse, which I've long been fond of. And
I'm speaking, of course, of Ecclesiastes
1:9.
Actually, Ecclesiastes is by far one of
my favorite books in the entire Bible.
But 1:9 reads as follows, and I'm sure
you've heard it or heard heard it
paraphrased before.
It goes as follows, quote, "What has
been will be again. What has been done
will be done again.
There is nothing new under the sun."
In other words, everything is cyclical.
Uh everything takes on new forms and
guises, but it's really at essence the
same thing. And uh that's exactly what I
believe. In many ways, if you want to
know, the story of Christianity from the
times of Christ till the very present
has been, well, caught by that verse
about there's nothing new in the sun
under the sun, because what was has been
and what was will will be again, because
there's nothing new under the sun. And I
mean specifically in the context of what
we're going to talk about, which is
Satan's two swords,
which have been, from the times of
Christ till the present,
bloodying Christians everywhere.
Okay? One sword is physical and overt,
and it is the sword that kills. And one
sword one sword is spiritual and covert.
And this is also kills kills the soul.
Okay? Which, again, most people don't
even know what that means anymore,
including Christians. Here is the quote
by Eusebius of Caesarea. He writes,
"Like dazzling lights, the churches were
now shining all over the world and to
the limits of the human race, faith in
our savior and Lord Jesus Christ was at
its peak.
He's talking about the date after 313
following the rise of Constantine, okay?
Who was his contemporary.
He continues.
So, the light was dazzling and things
were wonderful and the limits of the
human race faith in our savior and Lord
Jesus Christ was at its peak. When,
quote, the demon who hates the good,
sworn enemy of truth and inveterate foe
of man's salvation, turned all his
weapons against the church. Okay?
He continues.
In earlier days, he, this demon,
had attacked her, the church, with
persecutions from without.
He's talking about for, you know, about
250 years beginning with Emperor Nero
around AD 60-ish and ending with the
Emperor Diocletian around AD 311
where persecution of Christians was
horrific. So, he's saying, in earlier
days,
>> [snorts]
>> Satan had attacked the church with
persecutions from without
during that era I gave you.
He continues. But now that he was
debarred from this,
following the rise of Constantine, now
Christianity is spread, it's protected,
it's not allowed to be persecuted. He
continues. Now that he was debarred from
this, he resorted to unscrupulous
impostors
as instruments of spiritual corruption
and ministers of destruction
and employed a new tactics contriving by
every possible means that impostors and
cheats, by cloaking themselves with the
same name as our religion, in other
words, people who call themselves
Christians,
should at one and the same time bring to
the abyss of destruction every believer
they could entrap and by their own
actions and endeavors turn those
ignorant of the Christian faith away
from the path that leads to the message
of salvation.
Okay?
Now, think about that very important
excerpt because it completely describes
the twofold attack that Satan uses
against Christians. The two swords. One,
external physical persecution, in this
case from pagan Roman emperors, and one
used for internal spiritual subversion.
Uh in this case, Eusebius was writing
about the heresies, including Arianism,
which were rife in his day.
Okay? And again, what he was writing
then, I'm reading it to you because as
important as it is, it's actually what's
happening today. Hence, like I said,
there is nothing new under [snorts] the
sun.
Here's how Satan's two swords work.
Wherever possible,
>> [snorts]
>> Satan possesses his minions to use a
physical sword to persecute and
slaughter Christians, literally.
Where that is not possible, he uses a
spiritual sword to infiltrate and
subvert Christianity so that Christians
themselves, now being possessed,
choose death for themselves.
That's it in a nutshell.
Okay? And that is going to what I just
told you is more applicable to our day
than have at any point in history. And I
will prove that. As seen, the most
obvious and paradigmatic example
>> [snorts]
>> of physical persecution that Eusebius
that which was mentioned by Eusebius was
pagan Rome's savage persecution of
Christians, which was pretty savage, and
which, like I said, erupted from the
time of the apostles in the first
century under Emperor Nero, and
sporadically continued till the rise of
Constantine the Great, who basically
outlawed religious persecution in the
fourth century, specifically in
beginning with his Edict of Milan, which
came out around AD 313. But the physical
persecution of Christians did not end
there. So Eusebius dies around 339 and
340, and that's all we know about his
history because it obviously doesn't
continue after he dies, but a new
persecutor arises.
One that if not necessarily surpassing
the quality of Rome's atrocities against
Christians, not necessarily but maybe,
has far surpassed the quantity
of the persecution that pagan Rome uh
foisted on Christianity. And that
persecutor was and remains Islam.
Okay? Just so you understand why Islam
is has so much animus towards
Christianity, you need to remember that
in many ways it seems to have been a
cult or creed that was created precisely
to be set against and to devastate the
Christian world. Suffice to say, let's
look at some core doctrines in Islam.
All right?
You have to remember that Islam as a
religion
actually condemns Christian teaching in
its most core and holy scriptures.
That's pretty rare for a religion.
Hinduism doesn't do that. Buddhism
doesn't do that. Shintoism doesn't do
that. Confucianism doesn't do that.
Paganism doesn't do that. Okay?
Islam does in its core texts actually
condemn Christian teaching.
Bring back
the fire.
Bring back [music]
Bring back
the fire
in the
>> [music]
>> righteous name.